springing Kevin Millar one of the
reasons why the Red Sox won a World
Series at least according to Kevin
Millar he works for the Major League
Baseball Network as an analyst and a
member of the 2004 World Series champion
Red Sox you can watch him and Chris Rose
co-host intentional talk coming up at 2
p.m. Eastern throughout the postseason
as well all right keV Pauly has a Dodger
question that he is going to unveil to
you right now Paulie Kevin if the
Dodgers who won 106 games this year bow
out of the first round of the playoffs
well Dodger brass strongly consider
replacing the manager no I don't think
so
I think you know the one thing about
this Paulie is that I think that Dodgers
brass need to sit next to Dave Roberts
when he does his postgame interviews and
we know what happened last couple World
Series the first one in 17 when he took
out Rich Hill with four and he's pitched
seven hits one run few strikeouts here
and there next thing you know we can't
let the lineup face each other three
times in a row so we brought in Morel
who gives up the home run and it seemed
like it happened the exact same way in
18 Rich Hill on the mound same type
thing doing his thing there only 73 by
our curveball third time around we bring
in Matson and he gives up two three run
home run so Dave Roberts has hit the
podium solo but I think a lot of this
stuff is crew medicated at 1 & 2 o'clock
during a day and that's the problem that
we're losing right now Paulie is our
eyeballs in the game we're losing our
eyeballs in baseball because we have so
much analytics and so much premeditated
stuff that goes on which is information
yeah but you've got to placate the fans
at some point cap if they don't make it
to the World Series even if they go you
know three-peat and they don't win it
you know I I don't know what
management's spent on a lot of money
there you don't think Dave Roberts has a
warm seat that he's sitting on no big
cinnamon you know what Dan no no this is
a different this is a different thing
now we're not you Dave Roberts is not
the issue here Dave Roberts is a
love-love guy he does well he
understands the analytics that's not the
issue the issue is they've gotten the
World Series twice right they get to
this year
hard to get to the World Series by the
way I know there's only one winner and
and and the question would be if the
Dodgers don't win the World Series this
year is that a fuss of course it is
because they've been there and they've
lost they got dick today the
unbelievable World Series of 17 with the
Astros it was one of the best we've ever
seen and then 18 you know a Red Sox game
Novak's rains is like everybody's going
to bed Nathan Eovaldi said okay I'll
take this thing but the Dodgers are an
interesting thing because they are great
and if this does happen and they don't
get here you're like wow I don't think
they brought us get fired I you know
what Paulie said he then he was just
curious and I I said I I think that you
know they love Roberts and they should I
just don't know we're such a bottom line
Society certainly in sports where if you
lose again and you're right it's like
the Buffalo Bills went to four
consecutive Super Bowls and lost that'll
never happen again
and you know instead of we look at them
as failures instead of wow you made it
four consecutive times to the Super Bowl
so you know we were just curious about
that and this pitching matchup will are
the Dodgers going to advance how about
we'll start there yeah I mean because we
Strasburg has been unbelievable I think
Dodgers beat them tonight and Walker
Beeler's been just as unbelievable I
love the power this is exciting Clayton
Kershaw is coming out of the bullpen the
Nats will probably have everybody this
is what makes it great to playoff
baseball it's all sports really I mean I
can sit around watching every NBA game
you get suppose you're like yeah okay
let's go Lakers let's go
you know Celtic this is what goes on
though in sports is that it's played to
win the game right there's no more stuff
there's no more averages and blah blah
blah and brand play to win the game this
would be a great game I think Dodgers
advance alright
Cardinals Braves who advances Jack
Flaherty has he been unbelievable he's
throwing up like the old jakey air he
had a second half with the Cubs few
years back I think that was in 15 men
i'ma tell you right now this kids tempo
is just but I think Atlanta out hits
them at home I think authentically in
that small ballpark the Atlanta Braves
out hit those Cardinals and they advance
would you suspend Molina and
a Cunha throat the throat slashing
gesture I don't know I'm not smart
enough to know all that I know this
though I want a Cunha jr. to run every
single fall out yeah but that's not
gonna happen
why not why not in this stage dance that
too much to ask you tell me oh it's not
that you got Ryan McCann maybe a future
Hall of Fame catcher that you have lines
thicker that your managers been in the
organization 40 years 40 years don't you
owe them the respect for 12 games to
hustle and not worry about the branding
and the staring you can do all that
stuff okay what would you do if he was
your teammate this isn't like a fight
this is just a pitch that gives me 12
days of hustle on this stage 12 days
because 12 wins because we're trying to
get 12 wins that's it mm-hmm you owe it
to em populist who KB you 100 million
you owe to the city of Atlanta it just
makes it fun
it's not a word the word of the day
Kevin Millar for the Major League
Baseball Network joining us on the
program
yeah and the throat slashing it feels
like they're gonna hear from the
commissioner and maybe if there's any
punishment they'll do what they did with
Robbie Alomar will suspend you next
season that's my feeling although they
are embracing this whole bat flipping
and you know we played loud and all of
this so I don't know let them play right
you understand it's changed a little
which is fine I just need for the
postseason I'm asking for 90 feet 90
feet is so important in the postseason
as you see you know I think the Braves
in 91 was a game for a [ __ ] you lead off
with the double alby's couldn't get him
to third base they don't score tonight
Cardinals a sooner lose out with a
double they score Molina gets a fly so
the little things in the game the little
things in the game on this stage go a
long way yes they're more amplified and
that's why when everybody talks about
the regular-season I said the
regular-season doesn't matter to me and
how you play baseball it matters when
you get to the postseason because it's
about pitching little things in defense
it's not you know that maybe the Yankees
just plow through and hit homeruns and
act like a softball team but
to me it always comes down to pitching
defense and doing you know some of the
small things the Yankees might be the
best team going that we see now as far
as complete because I think going into
it everybody's like Astros you get the
three-headed monster then you see
Frankie kind of susceptible by God's 87
to 91 he's kind of mixing in a bunch of
changeup sports off you have the power
pitching of Cole and Verlander they're
probably the best team but then you
start watching the postseason you start
seeing holes
and who can get those tough eight outs
right because the postseason
everything's up they're gonna go eight
innings know this is stressful you get
six out of your starter I mean Verlander
dominated Game one right what do you go
seven so like you get six out of your
store these days that's dominating the
postseason you like what the Rays do
with their pitching Stone colleague
Kevin caching them I've done just an
unbelievable like it or not it's kind of
weird but I understand it when you got
guys throwing 98 99 miles an hour and
you can give me three different pitchers
Danny really the concept of bringing
your starter is a reliever as a closer
the concept is that they get so many
that's like a Swiss Army knife what they
have so that works for them the concept
is that just like what I told you
earlier with Rich Hill if I see the
starting pitcher three times in a game
the advantage starts going to the hitter
so that you're playing percentages
that's all you're doing
I've seen its curveballs changeup boom
if I only get to face you once through a
game and you've already bought you know
you bring a 98 miles an hour with a
nasty slider usually that's what the
package is that's tough to do with three
different guys doing that with three
different arm angles so what they do for
them and what they have in their bullpen
like I said a Swiss Army knife Kevin
cash and the Rays do such a wonderful
job but yeah I'm all-in for them but
everybody has that bullpen because you
see some games around here you're like
oh once they gets their bullpen that's
when the game gets a little bit yeah and
you know Atlanta Braves are one of those
teams
yeah the thing with Verlander last night
is you realize just it's so small the
difference between four days three days
rest where you might not have the same
break you may not have the same velocity
you might hang a pitch or two and
Verlander has been unbelievable
and you saw three days rest and and I
know
what they're doing they they thought if
we bring in our hammer we take him out
and we got coal to go you know Game one
of the ALCS I understand it how nervous
would you be if you're the Astros now
heading home for Game five well you're a
nervous wreck because I thought like you
know 60% of the guys that go on short
days rest don't win the game you know
the Astros going into yesterday's game
were eight and 13 on the road in the
postseason 12 and 4 at home so all of
these numbers are percentage right but
it was almost a must-win if you wanted
to get by the Yankees if you're the
Astros last night because Gerrit Cole
can then pitch Game one then you might
see Gerrit Cole three times in a
seven-game series against the Yankee's
now but he's on well rest rest you're
feeling good you're at gold looks
unhittable you probably favored as much
as ever Denny must game when five has
ever been but let's say they do win now
you go in the Yankee series with a hot
club that's well rested and you're like
might be the most complete club says
Glaber tours are turned into one of the
best players of baseball now what do you
do
also you get here at Cole maybe twice
instead of three times a beta-1 last
night it's good to talk to you Kevin
how's the teeth teeth are great I had at
the bottoms I have to go get him
actually filled in right now but it was
twelve thousand three hundred dollars so
I'll get about thirty thousand my mouth
I'm almost like Freddie Freeman John
Lackey and whoever else gets fake teeth
if you can afford them go get them you
don't get brush and Danny just like Val
I know but you know what old guys do is
they always get their teeth to wipe
right look great - I'm watching you
right now at TV we're just a little
behind on TV because it ya know you're
looking good man the hairs looking fresh
and let's go off soon please playing
that you're too busy you always talk
about bad bodies or I asked you about
bad bodies best-looking guy you ever
played with was who learn the shower
oh yeah get right to it yeah it's an
easy one right yeah second best you
probably asked me is definitely not Mike
Redmond the bench coach for the Rockies
his nicknames Michael bleakman because
the obliques hang over the
yes see well we started with Dave
Roberts do we go Goodbody bad body oh
but the Dodgers coaches had unfair you
know what he's actually he's asked a
really nice body he's actually nice he's
scrappy he's fast la xu c la Torre
lobello
you know plans so yeah babe Robert says
he's a wonderful human beings what a
nice you mean Europe meet and I'm happy
for all the success so the diamond have
done great whether they win the World
Series get to the real series of my
outfit does a warm seat there call you
fine good to talk to you have fun today
tell Chris Rose we sit alone all right
thank you thank you it's a Kevin Malone
Major League Baseball Network analyst
and he along with Chris Rose they
co-host intentional talk that comes up
in 2 p.m. Eastern throughout the
postseason for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]